[Musique]
bon soit tous on est un peu bousculés on
commence un petit peu en retard ce soir
parce que justement ce qui était prévu
d'arriver demain est finalement arrivé
cet après midi vous avez pu le suivre en
direct sur le site du figaro depuis le
milieu de l'après midi les premières
mesures de découpe du plan de
déconfinement annoncé par emmanuel
macron qui sont révélées alors on va les
commenter ici dans le grand studio du
figaro en et en direct on est avec vous
vous allez nous donner vos points de vue
êtes vous convaincus par les mesures qui
ont été annoncées qui sont annoncés par
emmanuel macron pour des cons fine est
donc désormais en quatre étapes
on en discute on en débat avec vous et
on en débat vincent trémolet de villers
bonsoir l'instant directeur adjoint de
la rédaction du figaro éditorialistes
politiques et avec lucile schmidt membre
de la rédaction de la revue esprit est
confondant trice de la fabrique
écologique bonsoir lucile on ira ensuite
son haletant aux invalides ou un
squelette en plastique agite
en tout cas plane sur le tombeau de
napoléon c'est la dernière idée du musée
de l'armée
alors ça fait pas autant de bruit que la
tribune des généraux mais sa suite une
belle polémique alors est ce génial s
abjecte dites nous ce que vous en pensez
ce sont donc les dernières infos et les
dernières nouvelles d'alsace qui ont
vendu la mèche première étape donc dû de
confinement lundi avec la levée des
déplacements inter régionaux ensuite ce
sera après le week-end de l'ascension
donc le 19 mai pour la réouverture des
terrasses et des commerces et des musées
des cinémas puis puis à partir du 9 juin
la réouverture des restaurants la fin du
couvre-feu elle est annoncée le 30 juin
prochain si vous comptez aller en boîte
de nuit il faudra attendre parce que
elles resteront fermés vincent très
molle et ce sont les infos qui nous sont
parvenues à ce que vous déjà vous
d'après des infos que vous confirmez
oui apparemment oui c'est le calendrier
tel que vous l'avez décrit donc en
quatre temps un calendrier très prudente
et précautionneux avec notamment un
certain nombre de choses qui
n'existaient pas lors du précédent
déconfinement mars avril c'est le
maintien d'un couvre-feu jusqu'à la date
du 30 juin alors ce couvre feu va être
décalé le 19 mai il sera décalée à 21h
puis le 9 juin 23 heures et puis après
le 30 juin les gens ont droit de se
coucher après 23 heures ils sont
autorisés par ceux qui les gouvernent
bon je trouve cette cette progression
horaires à la fois un peu infantilisante
et vaguement ridicule
mais elle fait partie de ce plan tel
qu'il a qui là qu'il a été décrit qu'en
dire de plus c'est très difficile pour
l'exécutif de trouver le point
d'équilibré puisque le le l'épidémie est
encore à un niveau élevé je crois qu'il
ya quelque chose d'un peu discutable
dans ce qui a été présenté en momie ses
phrases que j'ai fait sur le couvre-feu
mais qui tiennent plus que de l'humeur
que de la démonstration c'est le fait
que l'on fixe les décisions au taux
d'incidence le taux d'incidence est là
comment dire la circulation du virus
or l'important il me semble puisque on
n'arrivera pas osé rocco vide c'est
d'éviter les formes graves éviter les
formes graves c'est quoi c'est par un
certain nombre de 2 retenu dans les
attitudes et puis surtout par la
vaccination est donc il ya un moment si
on arrive à éviter les formes graves à
la limite la circulation n'est plus un
problème on ne doit plus décider de 2,2
de fer mesure de mesures aussi aussi
spectaculaire et c'est un peu un
un changement de pied de la part des
manuels macron puisque fin décembre je
me souviens très bien qu'il avait décidé
depuis fin janvier de ne plus décider en
fonction du taux d'incidence mais plutôt
en fonction de la capacité de l'hôpital
à résister à ceux qui qui devait s'y
rendre
lucide il ya une autre mesure phare dans
ces mesures c'est bel et bien l'entrée
en vigueur d'un pass sanitaires non pas
seulement comme l'avait laissé entendre
jean castex y a dans sa conférence de
presse pour franchir la frontière mais
bel et bien pour avoir accès à un
certain nombre d'événements et pour
pouvoir avoir accès à certains lieux
comme les musées ou les salles de sport
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
non je pense que c'est bien pourquoi est
ce que je pense alors après je demande à
voir qu'est ce que c'est exactement capa
sanitaire est ce que c'est praticable
comment est-ce que c'est opérationnel
parce que dans les effets d'annoncé il
ya eu tout le temps une espèce de
décalage entre ce qui était dit et la
réalité de ce qu'on arrivait à faire et
il faut pas utiliser au fond l'idée du
pass sanitaires comme quelque chose qui
créera ce nouveau décalage entre le
discours et la réalité de la wii la
liberté de circulation retrouver la
capacité qu'on aura à voir enfin à vivre
enfin je pense qu'il ya quelque chose
autour de ça donc est-ce qui a la
capacité à faire de ce pass sanitaire
quelque chose qui permet un principe de
précaution
un principe de respect des
responsabilités ou est-ce que ça va
entraîner d' état de complications
nouvelle il ya aussi cet élément là qui
me semble important
ensuite par rapport à ce que disait
vincent je trouve que on voit bien qu
effectivement emmanuel macron à chercher
le point d équilibre entre le fait de
mettre une perspective aux déconfinement
de nous dire écoutez l'avis va revenir à
la normale
et le fait de ne pas aller trop vite
parce que quelque part on a peur que
l'épidémie reprennent enfin les journaux
en sont pleins ça va reprendre sais pas
ce qui va se passer y aura-t-il une
quatrième vague à l'été
les variants donc il ya aussi l'anxiété
psychologique qui le dispute à l'idée de
savoir si nous allons redevenir comme
avant
donc il ya un élément psychologique je
trouve dans les annonces après ce que je
trouve je suis d'accord sur l'idée du
couvre feu
c'est que quand on rend les choses trop
compliquées on prend le risque de priver
des faits et de respect les la règle
là dessus il ya toute une théorie
sociologique c'est à dire que si vous
mettez le couvre-feu à 23h ou à 22
heures j'ai déjà oublié d'ailleurs à
quelle heure il va être je pense que on
va être on va peut-être on va être donné
donc là il reste il reste deux heures
départ du 19 mai 21h38 femme azza et
voyez donc si on peut être on va ça va
rentrer dans notre tête mais ça fait
beaucoup de différences et du coup déjà
entre nous entre 18h et 19h on
s'accommodait du petit quart d'heure
est-ce que c'est pas un peu ridicule de
faire à ce point d étape
je pense que c'est l'idée c'est
psychologiquement de montrer que les
choses ne sont pas jouées et qu'on est
parvenu à la liberté totale
mais alors ça suppose aussi une
politique devrait contrôler par rapport
à ceux qui ne respectent pas et est ce
que l'état on a les moyens donc la règle
sera t elle respectée si elle est trop
complexe en maintenant leur histoire
haendel bach a déjà les bains notre
justement une autre question à vous
poser à partir de sa pardonnez-moi mais
donc la première étape c'est lundi avec
la levée des déplacements inter
régionaux est-ce que c'est pas un
événement en fait c'est une mesure
symbolique une mesure politique mais le
déplacement inter régionaux en réalité
on sort d'une séquence de 15 jours de
congés ils ont pu ils ont puni l'on
puisse faire
je n'ose pas dire que le couvre-feu est
quand même largement contournée en ce
moment c'est à dire qu'on on est dans
dans une atmosphère assez particulière
et qu'il faudra analyser qui est
peut-être en fait dangereuse pour
l'avenir c'est qu'on établit des règles
dont on sait qu'elles seront qu'à moitié
respecter ou pas respecté et ce qu'ils
établissent ça et peut-être même les
respectent pas donc là il ya quelque
chose qui apparaît comme en décalage
entre la réalité et puis ce que doit
être la loi est normalement l'autorité
de la loi et le fait qu'on qu'on y
adhère donc là il ya une espèce de non
consentement aux règles qui fait qu'il
serait peut-être plus judicieux de ne
pas léser dictée quand elles sont trop
tatillonne ou quand elles sont trop
administrative ya un autre élément qui
m'est apparue en regardant la liste
et ce calendrier et qui pour le coup là
tous à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
profond et sur lequel il faudra rester
très vigilants c'est notre rapport à la
liberté je m'explique en général dans
notre histoire les libertés ont été
conquises au prix de luttes très forte
très compliqué très coûteuse et là les
libertés que nous allons retrouver
progressivement le seront sur décision
politique et administrative et c'est à
dire que nous vivrons une fois qu'elles
auront été recouvrés avec l'idée
qu'elles peuvent si un événement le
décident de nouveau être restreinte et
là je pense que c'est un basculement
dans de la psychologie personnelle et
collective qui fait que l'on en aura
toujours l'impression d'être en sursis
et il faut que les paroles politiques
s'emparent de ce problème en disant nous
allons sanctuariser la liberté nous
n'allons pas faire de ce geste politique
extrême qu'est celui du confinement
un geste politique courant et c'est la
question que se pose est-ce que vous
justement concrètement est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec lucile sur cette idée
du pass sanitaire qui justement est de
facto à restricteurs de liberté ça
dépend comment il est mort ça dépend
comment il est lui mis en oeuvre puis ça
dépend ça dépend ce qu'on met dans les
mots si vous voulez passeport c'est ce
qui vous permet de passer d'une part oui
mais si vous pouvez pas besoin de vos
enfants dans une école si l'on pas
certain nombre de vaccins une école
c'est pas un restaurant mais il ya mais
le je crois pas qu aura pas de
sanitaires pour le restaurant fonctionne
pour les apparemment pour les musées
pour les voilà laurent pour le mes et
ensuite la question sait de quoi il est
composé en fait c'est à dire est ce que
ces vaccins seule est ce que ces vaccins
test ce que ces vaccins test le test
sérologique puisque pour les gens qui
l'ont vu
je pense qu'il faut voir en détail le
peut-être c'est une restriction de
liberté mais mais elle existe déjà c'est
un peu comme la question le débat qui a
vu autour de tous antico vide on disait
c'est une algue ory qui va nous suivre
et c'est mais on accepte c'est google
depuis des années en finlande tandis que
ceux dont je parlais avant c'est dans la
décision administrative de fermeture et
d'ouverture
ça c'est clair c'est ça n'existait pas
et maintenant ça existe le pas salutaire
je pense que j'ai laissé la parole à
lucie puisque je parle beaucoup trop le
pas sanitaires si tous cache dans les
détails quoi comment saura-t-il établi
je je je je rebondis sur 7 sur ça parce
que justement cet internaute nous dit le
passeport sanitaire est inutile car le
critère de la circulation du virus n'est
pas fiable et on sait que le vaccin ne
m'empêche pas de trappe et le virus ce
qui est vrai en tous les cas ils
empêchent de trappes est a priori les
formes les plus graves mais n'empêche
pas d'autant que le sujet du passé ni
terre c'est surtout qu'aujourd'hui vous
n'êtes pas libres de vous faire vacciner
si vous le souhaitez c'est à dire que on
sait qu'il ya des populations cibles il
ya des critères d'âge sur le vaccin
astrazeneca le gouvernement s'est quand
même pris les pieds dans le tapis
puisque au début c'était réservé aux
jeunes et maintenant c'est réservé aux
vieux
ce qui fait que par exemple si vous avez
une cinquantaine d'années vous pouvez
pas vous faire vacciner avec astrazeneca
alors qu'avant il fallait avoir 30 ans
pour se faire vacciner avec astrazeneca
et on voit bien que du coup tout le
monde veut le vaccin finder quand il est
un peu plus vieux et que les jeunes
aimeraient certains jeunes pas tous
parce qu'en fait on voit qu'il ya un
clivage là-dessus voudrait se faire
vacciner ne peuvent pas donc si le pass
sanitaire ça suppose la vaccination là
il y aura une forme l'inégalité et
d'inéquité si ça suppose un test récent
pourquoi pas ou un test sérologique
pourquoi pas ça ça me semble important
donc on voit bien que autour de ce
concept il ya décliner concrètement une
politique qui n'accentue pas les
inégalités et qui ne prêteraient pas de
nouvelles frustrations
ensuite ce que je voulais dire par
rapport à la question des règles et à la
question de la responsabilité la liberté
c'est que au fond depuis le début de la
crise la pandémie on cherche l'équilibré
entre des restrictions de liberté dont
on espère qu effectivement elles n'ont
pas entamé notre goût de la liberté ça
je pense que ça pourra essentiel
est-ce qu'on va rester craintif moi je
passe mon temps à me dire ça je me dis
est ce qu'après plus d'un an est ce que
je vais être beaucoup plus craintifs
qu'avant est ce que je me dirais j'ai
peur donc est-ce que ça a durablement
modifié notre psychologie
la deuxième chose c'est qu'à mon sens ça
n'aura pas modifier profondément notre
psychologie ma psychologie cij est
articulé sa un sentiment de
responsabilité où j'aurai le sentiment
d'avoir fait le maximum pour la
collectivité mais aussi en toute
connaissance de cause et il faut pas
être infantiliser c'est à dire que le
danger qu'on peut imaginer c'est que
retrouver nos libertés dans un contexte
infantilisant phase que nous soyons
habitués à aller perdre de nouveau assez
d'accord avec un sens parce que
l'infantilisation l'aura emporté sur le
goût de la liberté il au fond c'est tout
ce qui est en jeu depuis le départ et
c'est en cela que la société française
chacun d'entre nous doit pouvoir se dire
je prends mes responsabilités j'accepte
par exemple pas sanitaire s'il est mis
en en oeuvre dans de bonnes conditions
parce que j'ai une responsabilité
individuelle et collective
donc ne parlons pas de liberté sans
parler de responsabilité ne crachons pas
sur le gouvernement
sans imaginer la difficulté de sa tâche
mais sachons réagir lorsqu'on a
l'impression qu'ils pratiquent
l'arbitraire ou la trop grande
complexité
21h 23h il n'y a pas un gouvernement moi
je crois pas du tout à la théorie d'un
gouvernement qui aurait profité de la
pandémie pour essayer d'étendre son
pouvoir je pense que ce pouvoir est
faible
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il est arbitraire
mais s'ajoute quand même à ce que vous
venez de décrire un autre élément qui
met en péril nos libertés et on fait ce
qu'on vide a été une espèce de
d'exercices collectifs à ciel ouvert de
discernement et de liberté individuelle
même de liberté intérieure c'est les
médias et cesser la pratique médiatique
continue je vais prendre un exemple il
ya quinze jours
la narration médiatique s'arrête sur le
variant brésilien quand on se plonge
dans ce ce cette inquiétude que l'on
quitte au bout d'une semaine pour tomber
dans le variant indien et on est
assailli d'image de dépêches de tweets
de signer de notification et devant
lesquels on est obligé de faire l'effort
presque athlétique de prendre du recul
d'essayer de lire les papiers et de
mesurer la réalité de cette menace par
rapport à l'ampleur du déferlement
d'informations qui quand on les prend au
premier degré sans recul apparaît comme
une espèce d'apocalypse à venir pour le
monde entier et je crois que dans toute
cette histoire maintenant il va falloir
apprendre ça va être très dur et et
surtout pour les plus jeunes générations
à à lire les journaux à regarder la
télévision à avoir les informations sur
les réseaux sociaux en conservant une
autonomie absolue de réflexion sur ce
qui se passe mais est ce que ça signifie
pas aussi que du côté des médias et
partisans du côté de l'audio visuel il
ya réfléchir à la question justement de
la responsabilité parce que il est clair
il est clair que le vaccin serait
efficace sur quelques cas de thrombose
enfin il est clair que beaucoup de
médecins considèrent que là il ya eu un
pilonnage qui a joué un effet de masse
sur le fil à être vaccinés gyms moi je
pense qu'il ya une responsabilité
collective tout ça semblait il ya une
responsabilité politique qui a joué au
début sur la peur pour imposer des
choses et qui maintenant aimerait
dégager les que la cram dont vous
parliez mais c'est un peu tard il ya une
responsabilité médiatique dont on omet
de parler et puis ya comme une
responsabilité scientifique parce que
quand vous avez des scientifiques qui
vont sur les plateaux en dix ans il y en
a pour dix ans alors qu'ils savent pas
comment ce qui va se passer dans un mois
s'est installée quand même dans les
esprits l'idée d'une épidémie éternelle
et donc le chacun il ya une forme de
d'emballement collectif qui fait que bon
alors c'est normal donc savais pas ce
que c'était c'est normal les foules
fonctionne comme ça mais maintenant il
va falloir essayer à chaque fois et même
dans les choix éditoriaux dans les choix
politiques de dire voilà on va pas
surinterpréter c'est une idée ni ni
psychose s'il fallait une idée ce serait
ça est-ce que alors plus première
question est ce que justement là le
point commun de ces trois attitudes de
ce trois acteurs c'est de ne pas avoir
joué sur les peurs et peut-être de façon
structurelle les médias et puis aussi
panne et des médias dans un premier
temps les médias ont joué un rôle qui a
été aussi de d'appeler la population à
rester chez elle avant de vraiment de
même déjà les dires de sur jouer ce rôle
est ce que il n'y a pas eu non plus une
brise ou une sur responsabilisation des
médias dont la le quand même le rôle
d'abord c'est avant tout d'informer
avant de huy enfin moi c'est comme ça
que j'ai ressenti et surtout je crois
qu'il ya je suis d'accord sur l'idée du
feuilletons nage c'est à dire que je
crois qu'à chaque journée à partir du
moment où tout jouer sur la peur il
fallait trouver une nouvelle peur et en
fait on a l'impression qu'on a cessé de
creuser ce sillon de la peur après il ya
un autre une autre chose que je veux
dire c'est que maintenant ça fait des
années que à chaque fois qu'il ya une
nouvelle peur une nouvelle difficulté
qui surgit on nous explique qu'il va
falloir s'habituer à vivre avec pour
toujours je pense bien sûr au terrorisme
et en ce sens on a le sentiment que
d'ailleurs le terrorisme n'en prend des
nouvelles formes et que effectivement il
faut s'habituer à vivre avec
mais si on ajoute le terrorisme la
pandémie le oui l'effondrement
économique écologique et économique lié
à la pandémie l'effondrement écologique
effectivement un effondrement la colla
sociologie enfin tout ça finit par se
demandent en fait qu'est ce qui nous
reste d'autres que caressait dans notre
guerrier et c'est pour ça que mon
inquiétude sur le fait de deux
resterons-nous craintif et craintive
moi je veux la cdas et je sens qu'il ya
quand même une
et là on entre ennui au coeur du
problème c'est que le tout l'enjeu est
de quitter la bulle c'est à dire qu' il
existe la réalité de votre existence de
celle de vincent de la mienne et il
existe une bulle médiatique aux
scientifiques au sein du tarot politique
qui n'est pas complètement dégagé de la
réalité c'est à dire qu'elle l'a reflète
la reine peut-être tel l'amplifient
peut-être la caricature mais qui nourrit
de quelque chose qui existe mais qui lui
donne des proportions qui sont dégagés
de ce qu'elle devrait être
et donc on se retrouve quand on reprend
sa vie concrète et sa vie réelle dégager
de ces écrans dégager de ses compulsions
numérique on arrive à prendre le recul
est à voir si on fait un exercice tout
bête on se dit bon ça fait un an de
pandémie autour de moi qui a eu le coc
vide qui est tombée malade qui
malheureusement parfois et certains en
sont morts et on peut mesurer on peut
évaluer de façon empirique est très
réduite sans en faire une théorie
scientifique universelle la gravité de
la chose c'est d'ailleurs ce que font
les français et c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont moins craintifs quant même kiki
qu'il y a un an ensuite séparés moi je
voyais aileron vaud valais on va sortir
un peu du sanitaire mais il ya un
certain nombre de polémiques parfois qui
prennent le pas médiatique et on en
parle pendant une semaine et on voit pas
que pendant ce temps il ya le centre
ville d'une ville moyenne qui perd cinq
petites entreprises trois magasins qui
ferment etc
et je pense qu'il faut vraiment faire
l'effort maintenant de ne pas vivre
complètement dans la bulle il faut
sortir de cette bulle pour essayer de
refléter le mieux possible la réalité
qui souvent en est éloigné
alors y'a peut-être d'ailleurs des
indications sur la sortie de cette bulle
il ya deux
deux extraits que je voudrais vous faire
écouter on y revient rapidement geste
après c'est d'abord l'analyse que fait
jérôme fourquet de la situation actuelle
et des dangers qui pèsent sur cette
fois-ci pardon on en parlait des peurs
mais sur l'exécutif
en tous les cas et puis peut-être
également emmanuel rivière en
commentaire du nouveau baromètre qui
paraît donc dans le figaro magazine de
ce week end et qui lui indique un autre
danger sur le pour le pouvoir exécutif
dans les deux cas ce qui est intéressant
c'est justement ce que ça dit ce que le
sahara compte de la réalité on les
écoute
le danger pour l'exécutif c'est en fait
de ne pas maîtriser le sujet qui
s'imposera au moment on passera à autre
chose et je la projection dans
l'élection présidentielle et dans les
échéances à venir peut se faire et ça
semble être le cas aujourd'hui sur un
sujet qui n'est pas très favorable quand
le sujet c'est l'insécurité liée au
terrorisme
bien évidemment cela peut profiter à
marine le pen
l'expérience historique nous montrent
que c'est en général pas au pic de la
crise économique et sociale que les
tensions sont les plus fortes qu'en
sortie de crise quand on a fait des
efforts quand on demande son dû et donc
là sans doute qu'à l'automne nous ne
serons pas encore dans cette danse est
dans cette période ça ne veut pas dire
que les raisons les ferments de la
colère née et disparus loin s'en faut
alors est-ce que c'est pas ça aussi qui
explique que la communication de du
président la république est très pearl
et qu'il marche quand même sur une ligne
de crête distinguerait deux choses il ya
le dégel dont on parle souvent et dont
on parle beaucoup de gens que l'on voit
au gouvernement où la majorité ce qu'ils
appellent le dégel c'est donc le moment
où on va sortir des aides le moment on
va sortir du confinement et certains
d'entre eux craignent des mouvements
sociaux moi je ne bouge pas devin mais
je n'ai pas cette inquiétude la revanche
est un phénomène qui m'a frappé après
l'attentât de rambouillet là c'est
l'autre sujet celui de la sécurité du
terrorisme c'est que on a senti un
basculement en tout cas moi je les ai
sentis dans même autour de moi on est
passé d'une forme de résignation de
lassitude à une forme de colère froide
mais de réelle colère et on le voit
d'ailleurs ont publié un sondage au doxa
sur ce sujet dans aujourd'hui dans le
journal de demain et qui sera en ligne
dans quelques minutes et qui montre que
le sentiment de colère chez les français
s'est décuplée suite cette suite à cet
événement et là c'est une difficulté à
mon avis plus importante pour l'exécutif
parce que autant on peut se montrer
compréhensif et indulgent avec une crise
mais pis démis que personne ne veut
venir et c'est autant emmanuel macron a
depuis le début de sa construction
politique écarter un certain nombre de
thèmes que l'on dit régalien et qui doit
maintenant
essayé d'affronter et donc il est un
petit lait toujours un peu en retard sur
ces sujets oui ce qui est frappant c'est
qu'en plus ces mêmes macron venait de il
voulait reprendre pied sur ces questions
de sécurité dont qui venait de délivrer
un grand discours programmatique et
depuis on a l'impression effectivement
que le gouvernement court après
l'événement avec en remettant l'objectif
des dix mille policiers et puis il ya
autre chose c'est qu'il ya cette espèce
de tensions entre la police et la
justice
avec ce qui se serait passé autour de
l'arrêt de la cour de cassation sur sur
leurs pairs sarah halimi ou la cour de
cassation
a décidé que le meurtrier était
irresponsable pénalement et les
manifestations et plus du vin plus de
20000 personnes dans la rue à ce sujet
un 25 26 min ça montre une espèce de de
colère aussi
moi je pense que c'est pas seulement sur
la question de la sécurité il ya aussi
la question de la justice est que là
dessus sur ce couple sécurité justice la
nomination d'eric dupond moretti était
était censé être un gros coup et qu'on
voit que ça ça a du mal soit disant il
va y aurait une loi sur la confiance
dans la justice mais qu'au fond
aujourd'hui elle ce sentiment d'un
hiatus d'un laxisme
je suis pas sûr que ce soit réel mais en
tout cas il ya deux ou trois affaires
très emblématique dia la question de la
violence des jeunes
les bandes de jeunes qui a beaucoup
inquiété aussi les français et moi même
je me sens inquiète quand je vois qu'il
ya des jeunes de 14 15 ans qu'ils se
cassent times qui deviennent des
délinquants
je pense que c'est il ya une intro
qualitatif qui inquiète beaucoup
et face à ça il ya la mise en avant de
statistiques qui semble extrêmement
abstraite et dont on se dit elle ne
reflète pas ce que je vis donc il ya
quelque chose autour de ça travailler il
faut pas faire des grands discours
programmatique
il ya un vrai sujet déjoué les attentes
a montré qu'on arrête les gens voient là
et je pense qu'il ya un péril qui se
présente pour emmanuel macron je parle
pas de jeu ne dit pas si c'est réel ou
pas mais simplement comme perception
dans la population qui ressemble aux
périls qui se présente pour anne hidalgo
avec la saleté à paris c'est à dire
qu'anne hidalgo s'époumone en disant
mais c'est une manipulation
la ville n'est pas plus simple qu'avant
et quoi qu'elle dise il ya une espèce de
réalité criante qui vient dire non ça
n'est pas vrai c'est plus simple
qu'avant et il me semble sur les sujets
de sécurité
emmanuel macron dit mais je fais ce que
je peux peut-être fait-il beaucoup de
choses mais il ya toujours un événement
parce qu'il hérite d'une situation et
d'un pays qui est qui qui est tombé dans
une espèce de violence basse intensité
dans certains quartiers en de façon
permanente et qui fait que la réalité
vient toujours qu'on contredire son
discours je crois pas que ce sera avec
des rodomontades pour en sortir c'est
simplement en agissant et en rime avec
l'inde en cours et choix des parents
avec de nouvelles voies avec
on parlait d' emmanuel macron parler des
médias il ya deux livres absolument
passionnant qui paraissent ces jours ci
d'abord celui de notre confrère arthur
berda qui dont les bonnes feuilles sont
publiées dans le figaro mais les très
bons livres de la plainte c'est plein
d'anecdotes en tout cas vous allez
découvrir en lisant des bonnes feuilles
déjà qu'ils sont soit sur le site du
figaro soit dans le nouveau numéro du
figaro magazine qui est en kiosque dès
ce vendredi et vous allez voir également
justement puisque toute la problématique
too le pose problème du positionnement
des manu macron sur les questions
régaliennes et également toutes les
problématiques de daemen mâcon dans son
positionnement par rapport aux médias et
à sa communication
et ça c'est un universitaire rémois qui
s'appelle alexis lévriers et qui vient
de publier ce livre qui s'appelle
jupiter et mercure le pouvoir
présidentiel face à la presse qui est
également une étude des relations
extrêmement difficile en particulier
sous la vème république
entre le pouvoir exécutif le pouvoir
présidentiel et les médias et c'est
absolument passionnant et donc de livres
que je me permets de vous recommander je
me permets de vous recommande également
le nouveau hors série sur napoléon
car mardi prochain c'est l'anniversaire
de la mort de l'empereur vincent je
voudrais pas trahir de secret mais en
vous disant vous aimez un peu l'île d'où
est originaire l'empereur et donc
on va aborder cette question là avec des
polémiques qui affluent la dernière en
date c'est cette initiative du musée de
l'armée avec une exposition d'art
contemporain qui est censé questionner
l'image de l'empereur après sa mort on
peut parler également je pense à l'excès
lévriers parlera du rapport de la presse
qu'il y avait avec napoléon à l'époque
et qui écrivait sa propre histoire et je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il en tout cas
imaginer que un artiste impliqué dans
l'exposition pascal convert
imagine d'installer une réplique en
plastique du squelette en cheval du
squelette du cheval de l'empereur à
marengo alors l'initiative soulève un
tollé l'indignation d'un des plus grands
historiens de l'empereur thierry lentz
dont on recommande également le dernier
livre pour napoléon thierry lentz dit la
question n'est pas de savoir si on aime
ou on n'aime pas mais si l'on doit
toujours le respect à la nécropole
nationale des invalides
lucile est ce que vous pensez que cette
initiative est un sacré la joue bien
c'est la liberté de l'art contemporain
écoutez j'ai du mal à concevoir que ce
soit un sacrilège mais sans doute que
j'ai pas pour napoléon la révérence ou
la détestation qui au fond accompagne en
général cette figure est par ailleurs
j'adore je le dis franchement j'adore
l'idée de mettre au dessus du tombeau de
napoléon le squelette du cheval qu'il
adorait c'est à dire que je pense que
quelque part
brusquement sa humaniste napoléon c'est
à dire que le fait d'avoir appris grâce
à cette polémique que napoléon avait un
cheval préféré que ce cheval au fond a
été une prise de guerre pour les anglais
que quand on se rappelle aussi que
pendant la guerre être enfin le couple
homme cheval enfin moi c'est quelque
chose qui me qui en fait me bouleverse
ça m'a fait penser à war horse ce film
de stephen spielberg à ceux à ce
spectacle que j'avais vu à new york sur
la façon dont les chevaux étaient
exploités pendant la guerre il ya aussi
un merveilleux roman de serge joncour
chien loup qui refait vivre les animaux
dans la guerre donc moi j'ai pensé à
tout ça et pour tout dire j'ai eu une
espèce de d'émotion par rapport à
napoléon que je n'avais jamais éprouvé
en voyant ce en voyant venir ce
squelette parce qu'en plus il ya une
espèce de alors j'ai compris qu'il
n'était pas encore exposé qu on pouvait
le voir seulement à partir de deux led
ou mais oui mais oui mais ce qui m'a ya
une espèce de côté très aérien bon moi
j'aime l'art contemporain croyant donc
très aérien dans ce squelette qui est un
squelette en 3d c'est un faux squelette
relisez donc c'est là qu'on n'est pas
vraiment dans la réalité et ça m'a fait
voir napoléon tout à fait autrement
et comme je ne suis pas la reine de la
commémoration je pense que oui ça a créé
en moi une émotion et qui à la fois
artistique et comment dirais-je humaine
en fait donc moi je suis pour bon vous
accueillir ce qui n'est pas le cas
kriss kross qui est dit c'est une honte
ce truc et nicole ce n'est pas que ce
n'est que mon avis mais l'art
contemporain qu'on nous impose profane
beaucoup de lieux
et je petit 74 c'est peut-être un
hommage mais de mauvais goût alors
heureusement qu'on n'avait lucile pour
défendre l'initiative de pascal convert
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vincent non
moi je le congeler découvre quand j'ai
découvert l'image j'ai pas du tout je
suis vu une émotion elle a été négatif
parce qu'il se trouve que c'est un lieu
que que j'aime bien fréquenté que je me
suis souvent rendue et que je trouve que
cette oeuvre abîme abîme le lieu c'est
quand même une nécropole alors on dira
si on veut pinailler que ça n'est pas
une nécropole qu'autour de du tombeau de
sas et muséal au monde comme quoi vos
panthéon bon et on peut même invoqué les
oeuvres d'anselm kiefer qui ont été
installés au panthéon sauf que les
hommes dans celle du fer au panthéon
sont magnifiques et sont parfaitement
ajustés aux lieux et donc elle ajoute au
lieu là moi ce qui me dérange au delà de
mon émotion négative dans tout le monde
se fout si on objective un peu les
choses c'est que il y a je dirais pas
l'art contemporain un certain art
contemporain qui est quand même à la
limite de l'imposture
parce qu'il ne se déploie que dans des
décors majestueux ou sublime c'est à
dire que si vous mettez les mêmes
erreurs oeuvre de façon autonome sur un
parking de centre commercial il n'y a
plus rien si vous mettez le david de
michel-ange journée on continuera à
aller l'admirer
là il n'y a plus rien donc cette oeuvre
ne dépend que de ce que de que de ce qui
l'entouré que de ceux qui l'accueillent
et plutôt qu'essayer de se hisser au
moins de se fondre dans ceux qui
l'accueillent
elle veut rompre avec pour qu'on la voit
donc il ya quelque chose que je
considère infantile et d' arrogant et au
fait de dérisoire c'est à dire que ce
serait une chose là est encore hors elle
partira et elle sera opposée à ce qu'il
n'aime pas du tout oui elle sera aussi
vite oubliée non mais c'est une chose à
laquelle j'ai réfléchi depuis longtemps
puisque c'est compliquer encore une fois
je sais pas si vous avez et au panthéon
mais c'est magnifique ça ils ont fait
donc moi j'ai pas de nos positions de
principe pas du tout il ya des choses
qui sont très réussis mais il y en a
d'autres où vraiment et pour moi ça
commence avec buren et ses colonnes qui
profitent du lieu du palais royal pour
rendre acceptable quelque chose qui
sinon ailleurs serait absolument
insignifiant donc
héritage des siècles avec lesquels ils
rompent leur permet d'exister
non un dernier mot peut être à 100 mais
je trouve que j'ai découvert à cette
occasion là aussi quelque chose qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé alors ça c'est pas
artistique c'est que le squelette du
cheval avait été récupérée par les
anglais comme synonyme de la bataille de
waterloo et que chez eux c'était au
musée est quelque part c'était le
symbole qu'ils avaient gagné oui la
prise de guerre et et moi je trouve ça
intéressant c'est à dire que moi je ne
savais pas du tout que c'était à ce
point que le cheval le squelette du
cheval était une prise de miers et donc
là il ya aussi quelque chose je pas sûr
que ce soit si artistique que ça mais il
ya quelque chose sur le fait de revoir
l'histoire différemment qui m'intéresse
c'est à dire que quelque part les
figures héroïques tout seul comme
m'intéresse pas trop
l'idée de la brillance meilleur cheval
m'intéresse l'idée que les anglais on en
fait un symbole nyr est tous à matériaux
réconcilier si on faisait une exposition
sur le lait le l'univers de napoléon
oublié dans lequel il ya son cheval oui
mais voilà avec des artistes
contemporains qu'il évoquerait mais
qu'ils ne voteraient pas au dessus du
tombeau a profité de la splendeur du
tombeau et du lieu parce que c'est quand
les majeures tu veux bien sûr c'est que
c'est quand même ça le problème
et ces essais très souvent alors je sais
pas si vous avez lu le livre de benjamin
olivennes non sur l'art contemporain qui
est très intéressant parce que justement
il ne fait pas que critiquer un certain
nombre de choses il fait aussi l'éloge
d'artistes contemporains très nombreux
et qui sont méconnus mais il faut il
prend l'exemple de kout où il montre
très bien comment kunz a le génie mais
les choses à verte de l'utilisation de
lieux sublimes pour exposer ses oeuvres
et pour finir je traîne que je veux une
fois reportage sur l'appartement de
koons qui entièrement décoré 18e et qui
n'est pas décoré avec ses déclinaisons
puzzle et son propre style d'un bon ça
veut peut-être dire quelque chose
d'aussi tête quand je cherche justement
les références du livre de benjamin
olivennes et c'est l'autre art
contemporain
grasset et voilà vrais artistes et
fausses valeurs j'ai su que j'aime avec
motion de synthèse
on était dans l'eau c'est un sujet très
intéressant est intéressant et c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est permis de l'aborder
et effectivement il vous fait beaucoup
réagir et puis effectivement il est mort
en mangerait un ami qui m'a dit de ne
pas aller on peut le poser plutôt avons
employé comme ça ça faisait le veau
marengo voilà imagination qui s'arrêtent
voilà c'est en tout cas bon il n'y a pas
eu de sanctions pour les pôles généraux
qui ont proposé ça aux invalides si ce
squelette représente le cheval préféré
de napoléon nous dit une autre on aurait
pu leur présenter autrement cet autre
internaute nous dit ça reste une tombe
est-ce que les gens apprécierait qu'on
mette un truc pareil au dessus de la
tombe de leurs parents nous disent
général escape juanlu estime qu on
touche le fond je dirais même qu'on
creuse alors je vois signal de roanne
que justement là le tombeau de napoléon
n'est pas creuser mais surélevé nadine
plus rien ne peut me surprendre au point
où nous en sommes ils peuvent même
perdre à la tour eiffel en rose fuchsia
serait pas mal peut-être pour justement
lutter contre la rouille profanes sont
le talon bonne napoléon en y installant
une réplique de squelettes à cheval vous
répondez oui à 60 9% mais j'avais oublié
de donner la réponse à la question
twitter qu'on vous pose et de vous
convaincus par les mesures de
déconfinement annoncé par emmanuel
macron dans la presse régionale et vous
répondez non à 68% on y revient dans les
prochaines heures vous pouvez retrouver
d'ailleurs toutes les informations
toutes les réactions autour de ces
premières annonces
sûr dans le live texte du figaro qui est
juste en dessous de ce player
et puis on y revient demain en direct
avec charlotte barillon de nuit pour
voir justement les implications
concrètes vous nous dites vous nous
posez toutes les questions on sera avec
les experts du figaro et puis on ira
également ensuite à rambouillet pour
l'hommage national à la policière tuée
la semaine dernière et ce sera également
animée par l'excellente charles bayon
dennebouy je vous retrouve demain même
heure même endroit à 17 heures pétantes
pour le dernier point de vue de la
semaine merci
lucile merci merci merci